do you think there there is a
element of
you know because when you look at
comedians what are what are some of the
dnas of comedians some of them lived a
very hard life right like it just wasn't
a cool upbringing so they had to figure
out a way to how to use comedy right
yeah some of it is maybe you're
and you got a person that is such a high
expectation person that you want to
humor him or perform or something like
what do you what do you notice being the
dna of great communities
like robin williams would you say that i
don't know i'm curious to know what you
would say i think they don't they don't
have good you know
family like it's not ozzie and harriet
you know i mean it's not that our family
was you know uh terrible i always have
good memories of it but yeah there were
some struggles my dad was a big guy he
wasn't real healthy and there was some
sadness there you know and so
there's always this combination of of
that going behind the scenes and so
you know there was uh
i don't know of any comedians that had
like really
perfect like where your parents were
um constantly
just
listening to everything you said i think
part of being in a big family too you
get kind of lost and you want to like
you know get more attention you know
so i mean there's all that dynamic going
on you know with our house you know and
so you know who knows it wasn't like
really i can't say it was like really
dark but
there was this yeah it doesn't i don't
think comedians that i know
have that kind of uh upbringing where
it's a little difficult a little
difficult and there's either a poverty
or or uh
some kind of thing going on you know you
know it's crazy i'm i'm watching uh a
lot of you and a lot of you know chris
this morning and i'm going through a lot
of the content last night today i'm
driving back i got an hour drive after i
dropped this guy off and
i watched a clip this morning of adam
sandler singing the song dedicated to
your brother i don't know if you've seen
that or not sure and let me tell you i'm
driving yeah you know and i'm like
i can't even control my i had to pull
over i'm like dude this is the end of
the song it's really well there's the
emotion yeah i mean listen look so i i
see uh one of the lines i
took screenshots while i'm driving so it
says i saw him in the office crying with
headphones on listening to casey and the
sunshine band song yeah i said buddy how
the hell is the making you uh how the
hell is that making you so sad he said
then he laughed and said just thinking
about my dad yeah so you can tell the
the affinity this guy had for his dad
your brother i mean there's got to be
that love that adoration was it that
kind of a thing yeah i want to make him
proud yeah he loved my i love my dad my
dad was a great man
and but he had some troubles you know
and uh he was you know and so i think
chris always wanted to make him feel
better you know he wasn't very healthy
you know and so he always wanted to make
him laugh and that kind of thing when
somebody's chronically ill like that you
know it's tough to have that in your
family you know so he always wanted to
make him feel better because he wasn't
feeling good all the time you know so
you know i think that's part of it you
know and i think uh chris had a huge
heart you know he had a huge heart he
always felt uh for people it very
empathetic you know and that kind of
thing we used to go visit old people and
he wanted to always go visit old people
in old folks homes you know and but it
was kind of funny too because like he'd
stay too long you know
i'd be like all right
this woman is
pretty sick
you know she doesn't have that doesn't
have that long to live now i'm not
leaving and they and the nurse is
staying with barbara
like you know don't yell and don't you
know feeling chris would be like hi
i'm crash
and an old age
and the lady be like one lady is like ah
get out of here
and then this other this one lady
thought she's like are you david my son
and he goes no i'm chris
and she's like david and he goes no
no
my name's chris and i'm like this is
confusing let's get out of here just say
you're david
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you